foreign
for all you curious kittens out there
Isabelle gets real about having sex with
Gabe and she Compares it to her previous
Partners really yep plus Debbie's son
reacts to her dating a man 43 years
younger than her you're gonna say hey
here Osama get on my bank account you
think I'm gonna do something crazy like
this oh you're doing this crazy ass I
just fall off the tournament the turnip
truck
she is from Georgia and so am I and that
is some country-ish I love it my mom has
always been such an outgoing friendly
loving character did he just call his
mom a character
I detect no lies
all right let's get into it Lord give me
strength
hey 90 day fans fam it's melissia there
was no new 90 Day episode last week
because of the Super Bowl so if you were
unaware of that don't worry you didn't
miss anything this week though Isabelle
reveals some details about her sex life
with Gabe and let's keep the comments
mature I know for the most part y'all do
that you're really good at voicing your
opinions but because this is a new topic
for many of us I know it is for myself I
just want to make sure that regardless
of our thoughts we keep things
respectful now some of you are going to
do what you want to do but at least I
said it
[Music]
all right Isabelle meets up with her
friends to grab a bite to eat her one
friend who is there is who introduced
her to Gabe his name is Samuel
Colombia is
as we know after Isabelle and Gay met
they went out to a party that night and
hit it off
when I spoke to Gabe recently he did
admit that he was wrong for not telling
Isabel he's a trans man the night they
met I 100 should have like that's why I
I never get myself in this position it
was just
everything happened so fast she learned
after the party when she looked at his
Instagram which is a tactic that gave
uses to let people know usually a girl's
like oh you're so cute I'm like oh
thanks I'm like they want my number it's
like okay but here look at my Instagram
and you can message me on there and so
clearly they'll know you know I don't
have to tell them because they're gonna
see all of everything so if they message
me that means they don't care and if
they don't then I don't get my feeling
sir clearly in this case Gabe was
fortunate that Isabelle liked him and
ultimately didn't care that brings us to
her friend being nosy but secretly
asking the question that I know I was
curious about you can't help but Wonder
um
contrast
is
when it comes to how gay measures up to
Isabel's past cisgender partners
definition below she says she has no
complaints he gets the job done
laughs
he's like are you serious Tyra is me
right now shout out to science that is
mind-blowing and if you aren't sure
about what she said
use context clues but
um
wow
you can say that again
but um
wow
concave uh knowledge
foreign
even though it is far from baby stories
who remembers a baby story
anyway even though we are far from what
it used to be I'm still learning a lot
we get to learn and have our drama fix
education and entertainment I am here
for it this is lovely
princess for a day now this is about to
be pure entertainment let's get into
Debbie I'm Debbie I'm 67 years old and I
live in Sugar Hill Georgia look at the
catch in the bag Debbie is moving to
Morocco to marry Osama who was 24 years
old and we don't even have to say
anything
before we get into her son's reaction to
the move and her relationship with Osama
here's a little background on Debbie and
how as her son would say she's become
the character she is today I love
painting
I started early as a child
painting is my friend it never lets me
down
the red winged blackbird is something
that's close to me as a child I always
wished I could be that bird to go away
fly away and not come back yeah Debbie's
been through some things growing up she
lived in a home with her mother who had
significant mental health issues and she
never felt any sense of normalcy or
structure as I got older I never knew
what a healthy relationship should look
like
I was very very naive so I was very
trusting
hmm
yeah Debbie has been married twice her
first marriage lasted four years that's
when she had her son Julian and her
second marriage lasted 23 years it ended
because her husband was having an affair
with another woman in another country
isn't that something love doesn't come
in that nice neat little package that we
thought so as the little girls you know
we thought oh our Prince Charming's
coming well they don't teach you that
you know sometimes it's the big bad wolf
Debbie is preaching for 12 years
I sat behind closed doors
I swore off men
until
I met Osama when it comes to how Debbie
and Osama met he's from Morocco he is an
artist and a poet it all started after
he commented on one of her paintings on
social media and he was very
complimentary
and every now and then I'd get another
message and then all of a sudden he's
he's like a tree that takes root in your
heart you sure he's not another wolf
Debbie
[Music]
we had so much in common and he would
send me pictures of his paintings and
poetry and it encouraged me and gave me
hope that he was a genuine person after
talking online for six months Debbie
went to visit Osama and Morocco she says
at the time she knew he was younger but
she didn't learn his exact age until she
got there
at first I said look Osama I just can't
do this you're too young but he made me
see that it wasn't about the age and
circumstances it's about a deeper level
of connectivity I've known Osama a
little over three years now wait I spy
with my little eye an American flag mask
on Osama
he is not from America or are living in
America what's up with the pride and
Debbie has on a plain black one I might
be looking too hard into things look
Debbie could have pulled out an extra
mask out of her purse who knows but it's
fishy I've only been to Morocco twice
but after years of communicating Osama
said Debbie come to Morocco and be my
wife so now I'm fixing to move to
Morocco in two weeks
someone who is not having it for good
reason is Debbie's son Julian mom what's
up
I love how she just said what's up like
that Julian is a police officer and
according to Debbie they are really
close look I just appreciate the fact
that he has no filter when it comes to
telling it like it is why are you gonna
need all this people gonna see this
video Rob no osama's protects me really
Osama is going to protect you yes
come on let's go sit down and talk man
it's like don't get on my case ever
since I told Julian I was moving to
Morocco to marry Osama he's been pretty
hateful about it
he thinks I'm going to get used and
abused and he thinks I'm gonna be like
lost in the Sahara Desert or something
could you see Debbie getting lost in the
Sahara Desert yeah
yeah okay looking for my point of view
this guy's young okay he lives in a
third world country
he has no job this is 100 catfish
no he he's not in it for the money
what you told me of him is already what
I need that's all I need to know
[Music]
when I found out that my mother was
engaged to a 23 or 24 year old Moroccan
male made me sick to my stomach and I
thought it was a joke
woman sounds unbelievable for sure
Julian tells his mom that he's worried
Osama is going to take everything she's
worked for take everything what you know
do you think I'm stupid you're gonna say
hey here Osama get on my bank account
you think I'm gonna do something crazy
like this oh you're doing this crazy ass
I think you can fall off the tournament
it sure does seem like it even though
well at some point she's gonna fall off
a donkey
foreign
how do you know he's not scamming you
I know because in all this time he has
never asked for money
not yet right it sounds like Debbie is
still being naive for sweet sensitive
Souls out there it is a hard truth to
accept but you can't expect everyone to
have a heart like you that's why you
can't be so quick to give your heart
away my mom has always been such an
outgoing friendly loving character she's
a free free spirit you know she's not
going with eyes open
I think there's something sinister
behind this
I found the right person that suits my
personality I hate the fact he's young I
wish he was a grandpa but is she but
he's not I just want to enjoy the
evening of my life this guy has blinded
you this guy has tricked you
before you get married I'm gonna find
out what the hell is really going on
because I know damn well he's not doing
it for love
[Music]
oh I can't wait to meet Osama I want to
hear from him next week it looks like
Julian is taking his mom to a lawyer to
try to protect her this guy is very
manipulating he's already manipulated my
mom to move over there my son Julian
he's afraid of osama's after me for my
money suppose this happens like a fairy
tale what if I want to drop a little
money on him then stupidest thing I've
ever heard in my entire life I don't
trust Osama not one one bit
I don't either Julian
all right 90 day fans fam there will not
be a recap next week because I'll be out
of town but I'll be back the following
week with all you need to know mwah see
you next time
[Music]